graduating from primary school is always
something worth celebrating but for two
sisters the idea of leaving is
terrifying
back at home Gloria Magnus's father
organized for a gang to hack to death
their own sister the motivation was
money witch doctors tell people that lb
no body parts bring wealth a local
charity worker heard about the attack
and the sisters were sent here for their
protection in the last ten years 79
people have been brutally murdered in
Tanzania children are an easy target but
hundreds more have been mutilated
attacked and raped the root cause of the
situation is not not not having
knowledge of the issue people not
knowing what albinism is what it entails
people not knowing that people with
albinism are human just like anybody
else so if we address that that is the
moment when we won't ever hear about
these attacks and discrimination ever
happening again
charity under the same Sun funds
children like glory and Agnes to study
secretly in schools hundreds of miles
from home guarded 24 hours a day they
say they have enjoyed being treated like
normal very nice that I can understand
in where they are taking care of for us
like other students
the government has outlawed witch
doctors and the number of attacks here
is decreasing what authorities are
stretched for cash and it is hard to
police the most rural areas so glory and
Agnes have had to learn the toughest of
lessons schools never have all the
answers and they can only do their best
to prepare them for life outside of
these walls